I was 13 when I was exposed to the world
of fashion magazine particularly
Harper's Bazaar you have not looked back
since and I still have lots of fashion
periodicals everywhere I'm not a fan of
any particular style it's more about the
project the brief decline and what's the
best way forward so I guess maybe over
time what I'd like my influences all
sort of creeps in every piece of work
that I produce I always look at the past
for reference a lot of my influences and
I'm aware of the present very much kind
of make sure every piece of work it's
ready for the future so I guess this
kind of forms the backbone of how I
tackle every piece of project if there's
a word to describe it probably timeless
well I'm very influenced by a few people
in my life number one guy is taping
Bhairon he sort of made me want to do
what I do today when I was younger I
hang around with my friends she has tons
of magazines and I remember going to his
house after homework I would flip all
the magazines and look at all the
beautiful typography and design
photography and so on and so forth and I
kind of felt that I want to be in this
world I want to be able to do this kind
of thing for a living the president
design wall has ability to influence
many many designers in Singapore I feel
because we all look up to this award and
think it's one of the highest accolade
for me personally I think it's very
important the winners award because what
I do in the beginning I'm not so certain
myself I just set on this path
experiment that went with it follow my
instincts with no goals in mind but the
back of my head I do hope I can be
recognized by fellow Singaporeans like
they look up to me and say hey you know
you're doing good stuff and carry on
keep on doing this or we could
collaborate for instance but that's sort
of like proof to me that maybe this
award is worth pursuing for a lot of
people because it may open more doors
and hopefully I can carry on influencing
more people my advice to emerging
designers would be you have to follow
your heart whatever we want to do but be
more critical about what you do because
we live in a time where it's very
crowded keep on pushing
if you don't think your dairy then you
know push it harder I'm Larry pay
creative director designer of the year
you